hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well chapter three of
ein rands short book the virtue of
selfishness is titled the ethics of
emergencies and in it she's going to set
out what she thinks that that a human
being
ought to be prepared to do for another
human being in emergency situations
so she's considering emergency cases but
she's also providing an argument why
looking at emergency cases is not the
best way to to carry out ethics and to
guide our life so she begins by saying
that many people approach the subject of
ethics by asking such questions as
should one risks one's life to help a
person who is drowning trapped in a fire
stepping in front of a speeding truck or
hanging by his fingernails over an abyss
obviously the last one is quite
hyperbolic but we can think of all sorts
of other situations would you for
example give an organ knowing that
perhaps there's a risk that you'll die
of the surgery to help somebody else or
to help a number of other people
who are about to die otherwise and we
can go on and on and on so you know
these are sometimes quite far-fetched in
hypothetical situations very abstract
and sometimes as in the case of the
philosopher who did in fact jump in and
save a drowning child at the cost of her
own life they present themselves to us
existentially and we have to figure out
what we're going to do so Rand thinks
that the reason why we focus so much on
these he's because of the pervasive
influence of altruism and she says that
it is elevated the issue of helping
others into the central and primary
issue of ethics and this leads in her
view to a sort of false dichotomy which
we're not going to worry so much about
here we're more interested in what she
actually has to say about emergencies
and one of the key points that she is
going to make comes up a little bit
later in the essay after she's talked
about the nature of love and valuing and
stuff like that she says that it's
important to differentiate between rules
of conduct in two different sort of
situations emergency conditions or
situations and normal conditions or
situations and she says this doesn't
mean that we have a double standard of
morality you know that we have a
bifurcated way of dealing with things
there's emergencies over here totally
different set of rules for them and then
normal life over here that would lead to
a kind of compartmentalization that's
that's problematic in ethical life
instead she says no no it's the same
basic principles that are governing our
responses in in both situations but we
need to be able to distinguish between
these kinds of situations so what is an
emergency she says an emergency is an
unsure and unexpected event limited in
time that creates conditions under which
human survival is impossible when she
gives examples
flood and earthquake a fire a shipwreck
we might think about a famine as well we
could come up with all sorts of things
but notice these conditions so it's
unchosen and unexpected limited in time
and it creates conditions under which
human survival is impossible this could
lead to some some issues we might say
well what about situations where
somebody else whether a government or a
super villain or whoever it happens to
be created a situation in which these
conditions were going to result like you
know blowing up a dam and then everybody
gets flooded or you know creating
artificial famine okay that that could
also probably be considered a state of
emergency as well but a state of
emergency is an extraordinary time she
says in an emergency situation the goal
is to combat the disaster escape the
danger and restore normal conditions so
if we're thinking about you know the
drowning child being swept down the
river you don't you know get in the
river and then you know save the child
and then like look around for more
drowning children you know get yourself
a little house in the river and now
you're the the River keeper or something
like that no you save the kid get them
out give them CPR if needed get them dry
and everybody goes on their way and now
the emergency is over so normal
conditions she says are those which are
metaphysically normal normal in the
nature of things appropriate to human
existence so you know what are examples
of this living on land as opposed to
being flooded right and she says by its
nature an emergency situation is
temporary if it were to last human
beings would die and so she says that
it's only in emergency situations that
we should volunteer to help strangers if
it's in our power so she gives example a
person who values human life and is
caught in a shipwreck should help to
save their fellow passengers although
not at the expense of their own life but
this does not mean that after they all
reach shore he should devote his efforts
to saving his fellow passengers from
poverty ignorance
roses or whatever other troubles they
might have nor does it mean he should
spend his life sailing the seven seas in
search of shipwreck effect victims to
save so again strong distinction between
emergency situations which call for
certain kinds of responses and ordinary
situations in which those you know
that's not necessary right those sorts
of responses so she asks who should we
help in emergencies and here is where
you know the the ethics of egoism really
is central here and she says that you
shouldn't be willing to sacrifice
anything whatsoever for anybody she says
let's consider a drowning person is the
person that's drowning a stranger or
somebody that we know if it's somebody
that we're familiar with so it's not
just a blank write a little head bobbing
along arms coming up then we should use
the following way of thinking about
things the risk that we incur should be
proportionate to the value of the person
for ourselves not necessarily the value
of the person for society unless we care
about that so if the president of you
know the United States is again bobbing
down the river I'll throw up I'm
drowning right and you're like well I
don't really care about the political
establishment don't save them according
to ran right unless you think that it
really matters as a matter of fact with
some presidents you might you might be
willing to save up let them drown let's
see who's next in line all right with
other things you know it's going to
depend on what that person's value is to
you and the amount of risk that you take
should be proportionate to that so she
says for example if it's the man or
woman ones one loves then one can be
willing to give one's own life to save
that person why for the selfish reason
that life without the loved person could
be unbearable and so she says the same
principle applies to
relationships among friends you know if
we can do things to help them and we
value them then that's a selfish act on
our part because we like having the
friend in good condition and doesn't
necessarily have to be emergency things
it could be helping them out with money
problems right giving them time giving
them attention all of those sorts of
things what about a case of a stranger
well she says the drowning person if
they're a stranger to us then we can
save them only when the danger to one's
own life is minimal here's where she
says something really interesting when
the danger is great it would actually be
immoral to attempt it so people that we
have no connection no attachment to they
are just bare human beings we can help
them if we want to but we shouldn't be
taking great risks in order to do so and
you know these risks could be to life
they could be to property they could be
to other relationships you know for
example if I you know value my
relationship with my spouse and there's
somebody else who is so despondent
because of her relationship which is a
very bad one with her spouse and she's
thinking about jumping off the bridge
I shouldn't say listen all love you as
much as he was supposed to because that
would be a you know they'd be taking
something away from my spouse I'd be
risking my own marriage to help this
other person and Rand would say well
that's foolish that's that's yeah
irrational and thereby immoral now she
does talk about a kind of generalized
respect and goodwill that we should
grant to a human being in the name of
the potential value they represent until
and unless they forfeit so somebody is
you know shown us that they're actually
a bad person well we don't owe them
anything in that case if we see them
drowning you know we don't just step on
their head
but we don't have to save them either
and there's this generalized sort of
good
will that that takes place so you know
she says a rational person does not
forget that life as a source of all
values and a common bond among living
things that other people are potentially
able to achieve the same virtues as
their own and thus we have enormous
value to him notice that there's still
self-regarding stuff going on there that
doesn't mean that this person should
regard human lives is interchangeable
with their own he just recognizes the
fact that his own life is the source not
only of all his values but his capacity
to values so we can extend this she says
respect goodwill towards other human
beings and we say other people are a
value because they're the same species
as our self so she says it's on the
ground of that generalized goodwill and
respect for the value of human life that
one helps strangers in an emergency and
only in an emergency and only to the
degree that it's it's still safe for us
to do so all right because that
generalized respect and goodwill does
not compel us to risk our own lives or
even you know take on certainty of
destruction or maiming or something like
that to help others so the general idea
here running throughout this is that
emergencies do furnish us cases where we
should act to help others to some degree
within certain limits depending on their
value to us but we should not be taking
emergencies as the criteria by which we
work out our ethics Rand thinks that
that is a fundamental mistake we need to
see emergency situations as precisely
that emergency situations that we handle
differently but we handle differently
using the same ethical principles as we
would for our ordinary as she calls it
normal conditions of life
you